I like when you talk about your dad your
dad took you or you took your dad I
guess you took your dad to Italy yeah
which is a big deal you're an Italian
guy right it was a whole thing he hadn't
been back in 50 years right he came to
the United States when he was 15 never
went back I'd never been right he had
quadruple bypass surgery right right I
go Dad we got to go to Italy before you
just a father-son visit just a father
son look at you so we're in Italy we're
in chefalu where he grew up he's taken
me around he's like this is where I
played ping pong this is where I learned
how to play foosball I played soccer
over there and your grandparents the
whole thing I'm like overwhelmed I'm a
very emotional sensitive guy and I'm
bawling right and I look up at him and
he's like why are you crying I go none
of this hitting you
ah we're in your hometown and you're an
old man
you should be we should be hugging in
the middle of the Piazza right he's
looking at you like there's something
wrong with you you're not you you're not
even a man you're crying for get off the
floor so yeah but it was really a great
trip he's been back every year since uh
we've been together and he uh he's found
a you know he he's he's like the mayor
to town now does he like advise you on
your career and my dad was a radio
engineer and so therefore he thinks he
can advise me on my career but your
father's never done stand-up comedy but
he but he knows everything he knows
everything he's a hair stylist so is he
really yeah he does
my father was bald with a ponytail
he was so cool I used to borrow his
clothes all right he had red shoes I
used to pop on when I used to go dancing
when I was 15 people like where'd you
get the red shoes I go my dad wow he
wears these to work so he used to go to
work and dressed in you know all black
and would you go to the beauty salon I
would like to take your kid to work day
right yeah I'll go get my haircut there
oh no kidding yeah you must have had
some haircut oh yeah I mean you must
have really been very stylish about
looking back at the photos right I was
like I can't believe my father was a
beautician my hair looks like you
think you'd have the best haircut
that was not the case
foreign